welche Note hat sich die Ampel verdient
in diesem ersten Jahr die Opposition
sagt ich würde der Ampel im Moment eine
vier minus geben und sie ausdrücklich
als versetzungsgefährdet betrachten
definitiv ungenügend ist jetzt nicht so
überraschend genauso wenig wie das was
die Ampel selbst sagt abgesehen
vielleicht von der Einigkeit also ich
würde uns eine 2 geben gut die Wahrheit
liegt wohl irgendwo in der Mitte die
Frage ist wo genau liegt sie ja das
wollten wir wissen wir das heißt das
Team von Inside politics und dazu haben
wir erstens die wichtigsten
Politikbereiche angeschaut der Corona
Entlastung Klima und so weiter und
zweitens haben wir auch auf die Soft
Skills geguckt früher hieß das Kopfnoten
Fleiß betragen solche Sachen ja wer hat
gestört wir kommen am Ende zu einer
Gesamtnote und auf dem Weg dahin nehmen
wir euch wie immer mit hinter die
Kulissen hinter unsere eigenen
ZDF-Hauptstadtstudio
schön dass es hier wir waren auch wieder
auf den Fluren des Bundestags für diese
Folge unser Hospital Jonas hier zu sehen
hat sich umgehört und manch
überraschendes gehört als ich in der
ersten Klasse war stand drüber fällt
durch ihre schwarzhaftigkeit auf ja die
Kommunikation die ist natürlich auch ein
Teil der Bewertung inklusive Vokabelheft
ermöglichungsministerium unten Blick auf
das was nicht so gut geklappt hat
also unsere insight-politik
Zeugnisausgabe XXL welche Gesamtnote
kriegt die Ampel für ihr erstes Jahr
fällt sie durch oder rechts für die
Versetzung wir zeigen euch nicht nur
Schritt für Schritt wie wir zu unseren
Note kommen sondern am Ende seid ihr
dran dann könnt ihr benutzen also
ja kommen wir also zu unserer ersten
Kopfnote
um die zu beurteilen haben wir jetzt
jemanden engagiert den ihr vermutlich
kennt aus dem Fernsehen meine Kollegin
sharkunta benegy die fürs ZDF
Hauptstadtstudio die Bundespolitik
analysiert für unsere
Nachrichtensendungen heute und heute
journal und wenn sie da gerade nicht
sitzt dann ist sie wahrscheinlich in
irgendeinem Hintergrundgespräch in
Berlin das sind Gespräche wo Politiker
Journalisten einladen wo man dann
vertraulicher spricht aus diesen
Gesprächen darf auch nichts nach außen
dringend und dazu will ich sie jetzt mal
befragen und zwar in einem Ort wo unter
anderem z.B auch er hier oft sitzt oder
er oder sie oder er oder eben sagt
ja wir reden ja immer vom Schlüsselloch
Blick den wir euch ermöglichen wollen
jetzt machen wir es mal wortwörtlich und
machen einen kleinen Perspektivwechsel
da könnt ihr ja hey hallo
man kann sich dran gewöhnen aber wohnen
würde ich hier nicht wollen das also
jetzt deine Perspektive hier das ist ja
das ist das was ich sehe wenn ich
schalten mache also du kannst sehen dass
ich mich hier auf dem auf dem Bildschirm
sehen kann man kann dann Text drauf
werfen hier auf diese Glasscheibe das
mache ich aber meistens nicht ich habe
mein Zeug immer hier liegen das ist dann
das was ich so ungefähr erzählen will
weißt du erzählst oft auch über die
Atmosphäre in der Ampel darüber wollen
wir jetzt auch sprechen wir haben ja
noch alle diesen selfie Spirit von
Beginn der koalitionsverhandlung noch in
Erinnerung das hat sich dann aber jetzt
ziemlich schnell geändert ne guck mal
uns noch mal hier so einige Zitate an
das Prinzip geht so Auftritte filmreif
handwerkliche Umsetzung bedenklich und
am Ende zahlt der Bürger drauf
die schlechte Performance des
Bundeskanzlers seine miesen Umfragewerte
Erinnerungslücken bei Warburg und seine
Verantwortung bei North Stream 2 werden
durch unloyales Verhalten und Missgunst
in der Koalition nicht geheilt werden
ja das war ja schon ziemlicher Sprung
wirst du das übers Jahr erlebt ja das
stimmt das war eine ganz schöne
Entwicklung weil am Anfang waren ja alle
total happy waren mit diesem rosa selfie
Image unterwegs und haben vor allem
gesagt wir machen das ganz gemeinsam wir
machen alles anders als die anderen hier
wird nicht gestritten wir müssen das zu
dritt irgendwie über die Bühne bringen
und mittlerweile ist genau das Gegenteil
der Fall man hat irgendwie das Gefühl
jeder streitet permanent mit jedem da
ist ein ganz anderer Sound reingekommen
also das Versprechen vom Anfang ist
eigentlich kaum noch wieder zu erkennen
die Absender den einen Kipppunkt oder
festmachen könntest Kipppunkt würde ich
nicht sagen das wäre so ein singuläres
Ereignis wo man sagen könnte da haben
sich alle gestritten aber das gab es so
nicht was es gab war so ein Moment wo
man zum ersten Mal eine richtige Unruhe
gespürt hat das war als Olaf Scholz im
Bundestag die 100 Milliarden Mittel für
die Bundeswehr angekündigt hat da waren
die Grünen ehrlich irritiert man hat
gemerkt sie waren irgendwie total
beunruhigt und fühlten sich nicht
mitgenommen
begeisterte dann hier in Berlin sehr
lange die Frage rum wer wusste vorher
von den 100 Milliarden war das nur
Scholz wann das Scholz und Lindner waren
vielleicht Habeck und baerbock auch
eingeweiht haben aber ihren eigenen
Leuten nichts gesagt also da kam zum
ersten mal so eine Unwucht rein wo diese
harmonische Kommunikation aufgebrochen
ist und seitdem sind auch alle sehr
empfindlich bei der Frage ob wirklich
jeder eingebunden worden ist wenn man
ein Minister vor die Kamera tritt und
irgendjemand sagt davon wusste ich
vorher nichts dann gibt es gleich
irgendwie Unruhe
zusammenfassen unter der Kopfnote
betragen was für eine Note wird zu geben
ja ich würde das glaube ich zwei Teilen
weil man muss am Anfang sagen das war
wirklich total interessant da hatten sie
sozusagen eins mit so einem fleißig
Sternchen alle sind total nett sondern
alle raufen sich auch zusammen und
mittlerweile so als Zwischenzeugnis bin
ich eher so bei einer 4+ weil da gibt's
noch relativ viel Möglichkeiten und Raum
für Harmonie für bloß das heißt also 3,7
könnte man sagen und irgendwie einen
Daumen drücken für gebt euch mal mehr
Mühe alles klar wird notiert so und
jetzt das Aufreger Thema schlechthin
dass die Ampel geerbt hat
[Musik]
ja diesem Thema hat sich bei uns im
Inside politics Team Christiane
ausführlich gewidmets in den letzten
bald drei Jahren und die erreichen wir
jetzt in der U-Bahn Christiane wie sah
denn der ampelkurs aus bei Corona in
diesem ersten Jahr da ist die Ampel
zerrissen und wie sehr das kann man ganz
gut erklären in der maskenpflicht hier
im ÖPNV wir sind ja eines der ganz
wenigen Länder in Europa die sie
überhaupt noch haben wobei auch bei uns
halten sich inzwischen nicht mehr alle
dran und kontrolliert jetzt auch nur
noch mit halber Kraft das kennt ihr
sicher alle ausdrücklich unterstützt
wird die Maske vom SPD
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach der
Justizminister von der FDP muss man also
ebenfalls aus der Regierung der findet
wir könnten die Masken längst weglassen
die beiden Minister haben sich jetzt ein
Jahr lang immer wieder gezockt um das
Thema Corona Verhältnis zum
Bundesjustizminister zu Marco Buschmann
gut wir haben also sehr häufig eine
andere Meinung die Bundesländer die
haben zum Teil auch unterschiedliche
Meinungen Bayern und Schleswig-Holstein
zum Beispiel die haben angekündigt die
maskenpflicht im ÖPNV auslaufen zu
lassen unter Missbilligung von Karl
Lauterbach ja und wie sieht es jetzt aus
mit der Maske im Fernverkehr ja da wird
es dann ganz verrückt säße ich nämlich
gerade im Flieger bräuchte ich die Maske
nicht mehr wäre ich aber im Fernzug der
Deutschen Bahn dann sehr wohl ich weiß
nicht wie es euch geht ich finde das
widersprüchlich aber der
Gesundheitsminister sagt man können die
beiden Verkehrsmittel nicht vergleichen
Zitat Karl Lauterbach nur ganz wenige
Menschen kommen jeden Tag mit dem
Flugzeug zur Arbeit aber Millionen mit
Bus oder Bahn ich finde das total
seltsames Argument denn mal ehrlich in
beiden Verkehrsmitteln ganz eng werden
mit vielen Menschen in geschlossenem
Raum ja und bei der isolationspflicht da
gehen die Meinung auch auseinander ja
wenn ich mich heute mit Corona infiziere
dann kommt ein bisschen drauf an wo ich
wohne in diesen fünf Bundesländern muss
ich mich nicht mehr isolieren in allen
anderen aber schon also den berühmten
föderalen Flickenteppich den hat auch
die Ampel nicht einmotten können so
gerade noch in der U-Bahn jetzt schon
auf unsere Showbühne Christiane hi hallo
wir hatten gerade das Thema Isolierung
bei Corona isoliert scheint vor allem
Karl Lauterbach selbst in vielen Fragen
zuletzt du hast ja auch ein eigenes
Video zu gemacht den Link hier ja
Stichwort impfen wie sieht denn da aus
ja du erinnerst dich impfen ist die
Lösung das war und ist auch Lauterbachs
Motto aber auch die Ampel konnte die
Impfquote eben nicht mehr spürbar
steigern
78% der Deutschen sind stand heute
einmal geimpft und 22% der Deutschen
sind bis heute gar nicht gegen geimpft
bis heute nicht geimpft ist der wird
wohl auch nicht mehr tun genau die Ampel
hatte sich ja furchtbar zerlegt im
Streit über die Impfpflicht das war im
April wahrscheinlich erinnert ihr euch
und dabei waren sich vorher alle so
sicher wir können die
für Deutschland zum ersten Mal beenden
mit der Impfung mit der Impfpflicht wenn
wir aus dieser Pandemie herauskommen
wollen wenn wir die Freiheit zurück
haben wollen dann gelingt es nur mit
einer allgemeinen Impfpflicht ich
jedenfalls halte sich für notwendig und
werde mich aktiv dafür einsetzen ja und
auch hier verlief der Graben also vor
allem zwischen SPD und Grün auf der
einen Seite die waren dafür und der FDP
die waren dagegen die Ampel konnte sich
damals nicht mal auf einen eigenen
Gesetzentwurf einigen und hat die
Abstimmung am Ende sogar freigegeben das
war im Prinzip schon die Kapitulation
der Rest ist Geschichte die Impfpflicht
viel durch eine echte Niederlage für die
Ampel ja und auch für den Kanzler würde
ich sagen aber im Stoff den haben wir
jetzt zur Genüge ja also wir haben viel
zu viel Impfstoff bestellt allein dieses
Jahr haben wir noch fast 80 Millionen
Dosen übrig und der Gesundheitsminister
hat auch schon fürs nächste Jahr noch
mal drei Milliarden Euro reserviert für
Impfstoffe davon könnt ihr er noch mal
lass mich gucken 150 Millionen Dosen
kaufen mit den könnten wir alle sogar
zweimal geimpft werden nächstes Jahr
könnte Konjunktiv in der Theorie super
in der Praxis ja gute Frage wer will das
wer will diese alten Impfstoffe noch die
gegen die neuen Varianten ja
wahrscheinlich sowieso nicht mehr
veransteckung schützen am Ende werden
wir wahrscheinlich einfach ganz viel
teuren Impfstoff wegschmeißen gibt's
denn auch noch irgendwas positives von
der Corona von ne ich würde schon sagen
zumindest ein Versprechen hat die Ampel
ja bisher eingehalten keine lockdowns
und keine Schulschließungen mehr egal
was kommt und selbst ein Karl Lauterbach
kann Fehler einräumen aber natürlich nur
die die Vorgängerregierung gemacht hat
nach dem Wissen von heute kommt man klar
zu der Erkenntnis dass die Kita
Schließungen zu Beginn der Pandemie
nicht nötig gewesen wäre gut Christian
welche Note gibt es für ein Jahr Ampel
corona-
dir sagen in Zahlen 3,7
notieren wir vielen Dank Christiane
gerne
[Musik]
der 24 Februar 2022 markiert eine
Zeitenwende in der Geschichte unseres
Kontinents ja das war ein Paukenschlag
und dann fangen wir nach bei Thomas der
ist bei uns für Außen- und
Verteidigungspolitik Zuständigkeit
Thomas du warst doch viel mit den beiden
zuständigen Ministerinnen Lambrecht und
Werbung unterwegs auf Reisen ja nach
diesem ausrufen der zeitenwände was
wollte er darauf erstmal große Staunen
weil viele und da schließe ich mich
absolut mit ein echt nicht geglaubt
hätten das Scholz so einen großen Wurf
hinkriegt aber das war diese Zeiten wenn
der Rede wirklich 100 Milliarden Euro
Sondervermögen für die Bundeswehr
Waffenlieferung an die Ukraine das
machen doppelterbruch mit der zehnten
deutscher sicherheitspolitikern
Deutschland hatte sich natürlich daran
gewöhnt dass es einerseits billige
Energie aus Russland bekommt
militärische Sicherheit aus den USA und
sich selbst in aller Ruhe und gute
Geschäfte kümmern kann das war das
Geschäftsmodell Exportweltmeister und
dieses Modell hat Scholz mit seiner Rede
endgültig beerdigt und dann das Problem
war dass dann erstmal wieder Flaute war
Scholz galt vor der Rede als Zauberer
und danach erst recht es hat ewig
gedauert bis er endlich nach Kiew
gefahren ist um ukrainespräsident der
lensky zu treffen dass er das nicht
vorher getan hat dazu hat zum Beispiel
der ehemalige ukrainische Botschafter in
Berlin an Rumäne ihr könnt euch
vielleicht erinnern Scholz als
beleidigte Leberwurst bezeichnet ja das
war eine riesen Aufregung damals hat
vielleicht hat damit zusammengehangen
das ist auch bei wichtigen Lied
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine sehr
lange dauerte Deutschland hat am Ende
zwar gar nicht so wenig geliefert
Panzerhaubitzen Flugabwehrsystem und
vieles mehr aber selbst die eigenen
Leute in der Koalition fanden es müsste
noch mehr sein und vor allem viel
schneller gehen was man Deutschland und
der Regierung vorwerfen muss auch
selbstkritisch viel zu spät angefangen
zu haben ich habe den Eindruck dass seit
der Entscheidung im Deutschen Bundestag
dass wir auch schwere Waffen liefern mir
einfach der ganze Reihe von
bürokratischen Hemmnis haben dass das
Verteidigungsministerium schneller
werden muss zu genau diesem
Themenkomplex hier noch ein komplettes
Video gemacht Thomas könnt ihr euch auch
noch mal angucken hier oben gibt es den
Link ja und an dieses Thema russland hat
sich das nächste dann quasi gleich
angeknüpft China ja und China ist
wirklich bei allen russlandrunden in
Berlin sozusagen der Elefant im Raum
Deutschlands Abhängigkeit von Russlands
fossilen Energieträgern das lässt sich
irgendwie lösen die Abhängigkeit
deutschlandunternehmen vom chinesischen
Markt von Lieferketten Hightech die ist
viel schwerer zu kappen China das ist
das eigentliche Problem für Deutschland
und da ist wiederum das Problem dass
sich der Kanzler und die Außenministerin
keineswegs einig sind ganz genau
behrburg will eine werteorientierte
Außenpolitik klare Kante gegen eine
zunehmende totalitäre Diktatur und
stolzes mal wieder vorsichtiger er will
nicht verschrecken weil er glaubt ist zu
brauchen für die deutsche Wirtschaft in
China oder dafür dass Hähnchen Warnungen
an Putin schickt mit den nuklearen
Drogen aufzuhören z.B gut fassen wir
stand jetzt noch mal zusammen Außen- und
sicherheitspolitisch weil das sicher
eines der schwersten wenn ich das
schwerste Jahr in den letzten 70 Jahren
das einberechnet welche Note gibt es von
Dir also lasst es mich mal aufteilen
außenpolitisch würde ich sagen das war
echt eine schwierige Situation sagen wir
eine zwei bis drei bei der Verteidigung
aber der geht noch viel zu wenig voran
und die Ministerin ist eine der
schwächsten Kabinett aus meiner Sicht
haben wir auch noch mal ein eigenes
Video zu für mich eine 4 - okay
zusammengefasst das wäre dann würde ich
sagen die drei minus 3 - heißt in Zahlen
3,3 notieren wir außen und
Verteidigungspolitik eine 3,3 vielen
Dank Thomas ja und das führt uns gleich
zur nächsten großen Frage wir die Ampel
hier in Deutschland auf den Krieg
reagiert schnell war klar die Sanktion
in Russland die wirken sich auch hier
aus die Außenministerin z.B die waren so
sogar schon früh für möglichen
Volksaufständen gleichzeitig forderte er
hier in ich sag mal er bodenständiger
Sprache Solidarität ein wenn da jemand
sagt ich helfe nur wenn ich einfach mal
50 Euro kriegt würde ich sagen die
kriegst du nicht Alter ja was das
wahlfolgt gekriegt hat bzw noch kriegen
soll und wie zielgenau das ganze ist
unter anderem der sogenannte dazu ist
uns jetzt Andrea zugeschaltet die sich
bei uns unter anderem mit Sozialpolitik
beschäftigt ein sehr du stehst vom
Kanzleramt wo dieser doppelwumms
verkündet wurde wobei das erste
Entlastungspaket war das ja nicht es gab
schon vorher zwei im Frühjahr ja genau
und ihr erinnert euch vielleicht 300 €
energiepreispauschale für alle nur
leider nicht für Rentner und Studierende
die wurden da irgendwie vergessen es gab
den Kinderbonus von 100 € 100 € für
Arbeitslose Tankrabatt 9 € Ticket gerade
von den letzten beiden Maßnahmen ist
aber wohl mehr als schöne Erinnerung für
alle gar nicht geblieben Porschefahrer
durften sich jedenfalls 3 Monate lang
über billiges tanken genauso freuen die
Punks über einen 9 € tritt nach Sylt
heißt also das eigentliche Problem das
ist in Deutschland eine zunehmende
sozialer Schieflage geben könnte haben
solche Maßnahmen nicht angepackt
berühmter Tropfen auf den heißen Stein
aber irre teuer 30 Milliarden haben die
ersten beiden Pakete gekostet und dann
gab es zwischenzeitlich fast schon
wieder vergessen aber muss man bei so
einer Zeugnisvergabe natürlich auch
beachten die sogenannte gasumlage ja
polithandwerklich war das eine ziemliche
Katastrophe aus dem Hause Harbeck die
sein Image stark ramponiert hat schlecht
gemacht schnell gescheitert bei der
Abwicklung haben wir dann auch etwas in
der Form wirklich einmaliges gesehen
alle Hebel wurden in Bewegung gesetzt um
das Gesetz noch zu stoppen bevor es im
Oktober in Kraft getreten wäre die
sogenannte gaspreisbremse die aber die
Ampel nicht selbst gemacht sondern hat
das Fachleute machen lassen in der
Kommission die aber seine Kritiker viel
zu spät eingesetzt worden ist ja sowas
erst nachdem der Doppelpunkt verkündet
wurde hat die Kommission überhaupt erst
begonnen Vorschläge zu entwickeln wie
der Kern dieses Doppelpunkt
auch schon längst begonnen am Ende stand
dann das ab März 80% des bisherigen
Gasverbrauchs eines Haushalts auf 12
Cent pro Kilowattstunde gedeckelt werden
soll einige Kommissionsmitglieder sagen
übrigens selbst zielgenau ist anders
denn willenbesitzer mit einem hohen
Gasverbrauch sollten demnach mehr
Staatshilfe als Geringverdiener mit
niedrigen Verbrauch bekommen das ist
eine Art Prinzip dieser Regierung
maximal viel Geld großflächig auf die
Probleme schütten eine Art
beruhigungspolitik perfekt ja und zwar
mit Geld dass man eigentlich nicht hat
kommen wir gleich drauf schauen aber
erst noch mal abschließend mit dir Thema
Sozialpolitik auf die anderen Projekte
der Ampel in diesem Bereich Mindestlohn
beim Bürgergeld dagegen da lief nicht
ganz so smooth nee also da hat ziemlich
gerumpelt die Union hat das Gesetz im
Bundesrat blockiert und der Kompromiss
hat nun einiges von dem was vor allem
SPD und Grüne wollten entkernt die
vertrauenszeit von 6 Monaten ist wieder
raus jetzt sind Aktionen am Tag eins
wieder möglich
welche Note gibt es denn jetzt von dir
insgesamt für den Bereich Sozialpolitik
also ich glaube eine
vier wäre tatsächlich eine ganz
faire Deutschland und dass ich gerade
ziemlich viele Leute allein gelassen
fühlen dass die Schlangen vor den Tafeln
immer länger werden dagegen hat es
definitiv nicht geholfen okay notieren
wir Andrea vielen Dank danke ans
Kanzleramt und bis später hier im Studio
wir notieren 4+ in Zahlen also
3,7 ja andrea hat mehrfach angesprochen
all die Maßnahmen kosten natürlich wie
auch die Militärausgaben über die wir
schon gesprochen haben und deswegen
springen wir jetzt von Andrea Luftlinie
ungefähr in Kilometer weiter zu Britta
Buchholz unserer Frau der Zahlen und die
steht nun vor ja man könnte sagen dem
Symbol der Ampel wenn man so will Britta
wohne nämlich genau ich stehe hier an
der Schuldenuhr man sieht sie direkt
hinter mir aufgestellt vom Bund der
Steuerzahler mitten im Berliner
Regierungsviertel in Sichtweite des
Bundestages und diese Schuldenuhr sie
läuft und läuft und läuft aktueller
Stand 2,5 Billionen das sind 2.500
Milliarden Sie jede Sekunde kommen noch
mal 11000 Euro dazu und das obwohl
jemand Finanzminister ist wir erinnern
uns dem vor allem eines wichtig ist die
Schuldenbremse Schuldenbremse
Schuldenbremse formal hält ja die
nächstes Jahr stand jetzt auch wieder
ein allerdings nur dank ziemlich
kreativer Ideen in Wahrheit nämlich hat
eine Regierung noch nie so viele Kredite
in einem Jahr bewilligt wie die Ampel
und dabei hat sie auch einen Trick
bemüht nämlich all diese Kreditaufnahmen
auf unterschiedliche Töpfe zu verteilen
zum Beispiel na da gibt es ja zum einen
die Verteidigungsausgaben rund 100
Milliarden die werden aus dem Topf
Sondervermögen Bundeswehr bezahlt der
sogenannte doppelwumms 200 Milliarden
der wird aus dem Wiederaufbau bezahlt
und diese Töpfe das ist sozusagen der
Clou oder man könnte ja auch sagen das
ist so eine Art bilanztrick die gehören
formal ja gar nicht zum Bundeshaushalt
und nur für den geht die Schuldenbremse
das ist ziemlich trickreich in der
Theater dazu haben wir auch ein
ausführliches Video noch mal hier könnte
das anklicken
natürlich auch frühere Regierungen
Schulden aufgenommen aber das was die
Ampel jetzt macht das ist vielleicht
sogar verfassungswidrig sagt immerhin
der Bundesrechnungshof na der Vorwurf
ist legt die Bundesregierung sozusagen
Kredite auf Vorrat an und wenn ja dann
ist das halt nicht erlaubt sonst könnte
die Regierung ja eifrig Kredite Bunkern
um die Schuldenbremse zu umgehen und das
würde doch niemand Herrn Lindner
unterstellen wollen es wird zu der
Eindruck erweckt die Schuldenbremse des
Grundgesetzes sei mein persönlichers
blienen der persönliches fliegen ja
vielleicht ist die Schuldenbremse sowas
in der Art in die FDP will ja auf Teufel
kommen raus daran festhalten ja wobei
das Gegenargument ist sind krasse Zeiten
krass schwierige Zeiten auch für die
deutsche Wirtschaft die Industrie und
wenn die Regierung da jetzt nicht viel
Geld in die Hand nimmt um gegenzusteuern
dann drohe eine insolvenzelle oder sogar
die die Industrialisierung
nicht beklagen aber ja auch viele
Wirtschaftsvertreter dass die Hilfen
nicht zielgenau sind wir haben das ja
eben schon mal gehört Prinzip Gießkanne
und gerade bei der Energiepolitik werden
ja nicht alle verfügbare Möglichkeiten
überhaupt ausgeschöpft da kommen wir
gleich noch ausführlicher drauf ziehen
aber erstmal mit dir in dieser Stelle
inzwischen Bilanz mit Blick auf unser
Zeugnis welche Note gibst du der
Finanzpolitik der
sind einzig Gießkanne alles auf Kosten
der jüngeren Generationen dazu tut man
nach außen so als wäre man total solide
unterwegs also das Zusammenpassen von
Schein und Sein das ist auf jeden Fall
mangelhaft ich würde trotzdem sagen
angesichts der Größe der Aufgabe und
weil man sich schon sehr bemüht hat
irgendwo zwischen drei Minus und vier
plus das heißt konkret also vielleicht
eine 4+ alles klar notieren wir Britta
vielen dank vielen Dank an die
Schuldenuhr Finanzpolitik 3,7 und in der
Zwischenzeit zu uns ins Studio Gehalt
eben noch am Kanzleramt Andreas ein
bisschen angenehmer
wir bleiben beim Thema Kommunikation wir
haben gerade viel darüber gelernt wie es
intern in der Ampel ging mit der
Kommunikation jetzt wollen wir noch mal
drauf schauen wie die Regierung nach
außen kommuniziert hat das ist ja auch
wichtig ja gerade in Krisenzeiten ist
das besonders wichtig das haben wir ja
schon in der corona-zeit gesehen jetzt
im Kriegszeiten mit all den Verwerfungen
und folgen über die wir ja schon
gesprochen haben gilt das natürlich noch
mal mehr ja und wie hat sich die
Regierung geschlagen fangen wir mal an
beim Kanzler ja also der Kanzler und das
ist ja eigentlich kein Geheimnis das ist
kein großer Kommunikator auch wenn er
manchmal die wortbasuka rausholt und
never walk alone
sowas denken sich dann vor allem zwei
Männer in seinem Umfeld aus das ist
regierungssprecher Steffen Hebestreit
und der Kanzleramtschef Wolfgang Schmidt
wenn der Kanzler aber spontan was sagt
dann klingt der eher weniger Wort
gewaltig haben sie auch praktische
Alltagstipps zur Hand nö mehr sagt er
nicht er ist jetzt also der NÖ Kanzler
aber wir haben dann auch noch einen ganz
anderen Kanzler erlebt
ja das war bei der Generaldebatte im
September und da haben wir uns echt alle
die Augen gerieben plötzlich stand da
ein Kanzler der vom Manuskript abweicht
der scharf zurückschießt gegen den
Oppositionsführer der ihn zuvor ja
deutlich herausgefordert hatte sie waren
unfähig den Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien herbeizuführen sie haben
Abwehrkämpfe geführt gegen jede einzelne
Windkraftanlage und jeder Abwehrkampf
der letzten Jahre schadet unserem Land
noch heute das waren sie es gibt in
seiner Kommunikation keine wirkliche
Linie von Wortkarten bis Wort gewaltig
ist echt alles dabei und eins gelingt
ihm definitiv nicht eine emotionale Nähe
zu den Bürgern aufzubauen und das fällt
vielleicht auch deswegen so besonders
auf weil der Kontrast zu einem anderen
zum Vizekanzler so groß ist ja das
stimmt dieser Vizekanzler ist ja
gewissermaßen angetreten und politische
Kommunikation zu erneuern Ehrlichkeit
Zweifel Transparenz eine Sprache die
sich frei macht von politischen Stanzen
aber auch Robert habe hat es nicht
geschafft seine eigenen Maßstäbe zu
halten Beispiel akw-debatte immer wieder
hat er wiederholt dass jetzt jede
eingesparte Stunde Kilowattstunde
Energie hilft bei der Laufzeit von
Atomkraftwerken war dann aber plötzlich
das alles nicht mehr so wichtig die
sollten schnellstmöglich vom Netz auch
wenn es da um Megawattstunden geht das
Image vom Vizekanzler der das Volk
ehrlich auf Zumutungen einschwört hat da
echt stark gelitten so jetzt schauen wir
doch mal auf die gesamte Ampel die hat
uns auch ein paar neue Worte beschert
dass uns ein kleines Vokabelheft
mitgebracht ja das sind echt ein paar
hübsche Begriffe dabei den Anfang macht
Christian Lindner der hat sich gleich zu
Beginn für sein Ministerium einen neuen
Namen ausgedacht und deutlich zu machen
dass er als Finanzminister nichts
blockieren will nannte er das
ermöglichungsministerium ja aber da war
ja nicht der einzige seine Achtung
Ironie bester Freund Robert Harbeck hat
sein Ministerium zwischenzeitlich auch
umbenannt herzlich willkommen im
Ministerium für Wirtschaft Klimaschutz
und Unterstützung für auch keine also
statt bmwk Bundesministerium für
Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz
bmku sozusagen
ja ich glaube ich
glaube Robert Habeck liebt
Wortneuschöpfung als ich ihn kürzlich
gefragt habe wie man die Koalition die
ihr als fortschrittskoalition gestartet
ist jetzt nach einem Jahr Krise nennen
müsste hat er das hier geantwortet im
Moment sind wir die Deutschland
Sicherheit geben Koalition wow dann
nehmen wir uns jetzt mal die Freiheit
das Ganze zu bewerten die Kommunikation
der Ampel nach außen ins Volk sozusagen
welche Note findest du insgesamt
angemessen ja also ich glaube ich gebe
dir Ampel für den kreativen Willen eine
2 war stets bemüht das hat aber schon in
der Schule nicht gereicht und deshalb
sage ich macht einfach weniger Welle
weniger Wumms weniger Gedöns macht euren
Job und sagt was Sache ist ich gebe also
da noch mal deutlich einen Punkt Abzug
und unterm Strich würde ich sagen
befriedigen -
heißt in seinen 3,3
alles klar vielen Dank Andrea für diesen
Part was als Letzter Politikbereich
natürlich nicht fehlen darf das was
eigentlich das Hauptprojekt der Ampel
werden sollte
[Musik]
wie oft schätzt ihr steht das Wort Klima
im Koalitionsvertrag ich habe noch mal
nachgezählt bzw mein Computer nachzählen
lassen stürmen F Klima und insgesamt mit
Klimaschutz Neutralität Klimakrise
Klimaziele 78 Mal wenn ich das richtig
überschlagen habe fragen wir nach bei
David aus unserem inside politiksteam
weil David ist die Ampel denn da ihren
eigenen Anspruch gerecht geworden na ja
also auch hier muss man natürlich
erstmal zur Ampel Verteidigung Einräumen
der Krieg hat die Ausgangslage schon
verändert aber selbst wenn man das jetzt
ein Preis kann man nicht sagen dass die
Ampel irgendwie alles getan hat und das
Klima zu schützen auch nicht ansatzweise
das was sie sich vorgenommen hat fangen
wir mal mit dem Thema Braunkohle an da
sind ja wegen des Gas Lieferstopps also
Russland fünf Blöcke wieder ins Netz
gegangen die eigentlich schon Geschichte
waren und da gab es vor allem für die
Grünen natürlich eine sehr unerwünschte
Debatte nämlich Atomkraft oder braune ja
und ausgerechnet eine ihrer Ikonen hat
das hier dazu gesagt ich persönlich
denke das ist eine schlechte Idee ist
auf Kohle zu setzen solange die AKWs
noch laufen wenn sie schon laufen glaube
ich dass es ein Fehler wäre sie
abzuschalten und sich der Kohle
zuzuwenden aber die Ampel hatten anders
entschieden genau die Ampel hat anders
entschieden nächsten April ist Schluss
da gab es ja bereits erbitterte
Diskussionen vor allem mal wieder
zwischen Grünen und FDP und er Kanzler
der hat ja am Ende sein berühmtes
Machtwort gesprochen mit der Richtlinie
Kompetenzen ziemlich schwer das ist ein
äußerst scharfes Schwert Angela Merkel
hat es übrigens in 16 Jahren nie gezückt
aber in dem Fall waren wohl alle
Beteiligten nicht wirklich unglücklich
darüber die FDP konnte sagen wir haben
bis zuletzt für unsere Position gekämpft
die Grünen ebenso auch wenn inhaltlich
keiner wirklich zufrieden sein konnte
mit dem Ergebnis es wurde gelöst Greta
Thunberg war wahrscheinlich auch nicht
ganz zufrieden vermutlich nicht Fakt ist
dadurch werden jetzt erstmal viele
Millionen Tonnen CO2 zusätzlich
verbraucht weswegen manche sagen es ist
jetzt nicht so sehr die angekündigte
fortschrittskoalition vielleicht sondern
in dem Fall eher eine
rückschrittskoalition oder wie Fridays
for future sagt das steht in keinem
Verhältnis zu dem Anspruch das 1,5 Grad
Ziel einzuhalten den Pariser
Klimaabkommen gerecht zu werden oder
auch dem was die Bundesregierung gesagt
hat eine klimaschutzregierung zu sein
wow das ist schon ziemlich hartes Urteil
ja da wurden wohl viele Hoffnungen der
klimaaktivisten bitter enttäuscht also
wer hätte denn gedacht dass nach 16
Jahren Grünen in der Opposition die
endlich wieder mit regieren genau in
dieser Zeit noch nicht mal im Jahr die
Radikalisierung dieser Klima bewegen
dermaßen sich vollzieht Stichwort Klima
Kleber hätten sie wahrscheinlich etwas
anderes gewünscht von der Regierung mit
grüner Regierungsbeteiligung in der Tat
schauen wir auf die Erneuerbaren auch da
hatte die Ampel viel versprochen hat sie
denn da geliefert naja also wenn man
sich die Zahlen anschaut kann man selbst
mit viel Fantasie nicht richtig große
Dynamik erkennen im Gegenteil wenn wir
zum Beispiel auf die Windkraft schauen
die Zahlen neue Anlagen nahm zwar bis
September laut Branchenverband etwas zu
um 5%, die Zahl der neu genehmigten
Anlagen sank aber im selben Zeitraum um
gut 16 Prozent klar liegt auch an den
Ländern aber eben auch an sehr
komplizierten Vorgaben des Bundes da ist
die Bundesregierung zuständig und da das
zeigen die Zahlen ist man in diesem
ersten Jahr noch nicht selber
weitergekommen also fassen wir zusammen
welche Note findest du für die
Klimapolitik der Ampel angemessen
ja die Notenkonferenz bei dem Thema ist
noch schwieriger als die Klimakonferenz
glaube ich aber also sagen wir mal so
wir haben das Verkehrssektor Thema noch
gar nicht groß eingebaut und keinem
anderen Feld hat die Ampel so sehr die
eigenen Ziele gerissen kein Tempolimit
eine euro-ticket in der Ursprungsform
jedenfalls nicht verlängert ständig
Streit zwischen dem gelben und dem
grünen Ministerien Verkehr und Energie
also wenn man den eigenen Anspruch der
Ampel als Maßstab zugrunde liegt dann
würde ich sagen was mangelhaft fünf also
ist hart aber
müssen wir notieren 5,0 Luft nach oben
auf jeden Fall danke dir David ja
nochmal ganz ausdrücklich wir erkennen
an dass das ein besonderes Jahr war mit
sehr schwierigen Herausforderungen was
wir jetzt noch mal ganz gesondert
herausstellen wollen mit unserer
nächsten Kopfnote
[Musik]
und dazu habe ich noch mal statt
runterladen in die Maske unter der nach
getaner Arbeit
hier ist also der Ort wo nicht nur wir
Fernsehen Leute sondern auch die kann
man jetzt Mitglieder zum Beispiel
aufgehübsch werden ja das ist eigentlich
genau der cool wo sie alle sitzen
Minister und Oppositionsführern hier auf
dem Stuhl sind alle gleich weil sie
wollen alle gut aussehen das ist auch
die Möglichkeit dann für uns mal eine
Minute zu nutzen und zu gucken
hintergrundfragen stellen und mal
schauen wie sind die eigentlich drauf
ist total spannend an Tagen wo viel los
war jetzt zum Beispiel nach der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz wenn sie
sich alle ohne Kameras gezofft haben
oder neulich als Harbeck mal die
gasumlage angekündigt hat früher in
diesem Jahr da kann man dann immer mal
gucken wie angefasst sind die Leute wie
stark stehen die unter Strom oder
schaffen die das sich hier auf dem Stuhl
wenigstens mal für eine Minute zu
entspannen natürlich wichtig dass alle
gut aussehen dabei aber es kommt bei
Politik natürlich keineswegs nur darauf
an wie man aussieht sondern auch was am
Ende rauskommt und da gab es ja schon
sehr sehr viel was die Ampel da
abzuarbeiten hatte Stichwort Fleiß wie
war dieses Jahr ja ich glaube man tut
niemand Unrecht wenn man sagt diese
Bundesregierung hatte schon ganz schön
viel vor der großen zwar mehr als
wahrscheinlich alle anderen vorher und
das hat dann natürlich dazu geführt dass
sie einige ihre eigenen Vorhaben erstmal
nach hinten stellen mussten weil sie so
viel Krisenmanagement zu bewältigen
hatten dass die eigenen Ideen naja ich
will noch nicht sagen hinten
runtergefallen sind weil noch regieren
sie ja und sie haben ja noch ein paar
Jährchen Zeit aber zumindest im ersten
Jahr haben sie nicht so viele anpacken
können wie sie ursprünglich mal vor
hatten und das war anders auch als bei
vorherigen Regierung ne na ja du musst
dir das so vorstellen normalerweise bei
einem Regierungswechsel sagen wir mal du
bist Minister dann kommst du rein und
hast du ein großes neues Haus mit
wahnsinnig viel Mitarbeitern du hast
normalerweise drei Monate Zeit um dich
einzuarbeiten bis wir als Medien und die
Opposition mal vorbeikommen und sagen na
wie läuft's denn so mit dem regieren was
kommt denn jetzt wo sind denn eure Ideen
und diese Phase die ist komplett
weggefallen die mussten Tag 1 an
regieren mussten von Tag eins an sich um
kriegsfragen um Energiefragen kümmern
und konnten deswegen eben jetzt nicht
sagen ich überlege mir erstmal ganz in
Ruhe welches meiner Projekte ich jetzt
nach vorne stellen möchte und mit meinen
Experten in den Ministerien bearbeiten
möchte und das ist schon ein Unterschied
zu anderen Regierungswechseln also bei
alle Kritik die wir äußern wie Medien ja
auch äußern müssen muss man schon auch
in Rechnung stellen dass da auch
ziemlich hoher Druck herrscht ich glaube
das wäre unfair das nicht zu sehen weil
die Belastung die ist unglaublich hoch
das können wir uns vielleicht alle gar
nicht vorstellen wir begrüßen ja hier
immer wenn wir Gäste haben die zu
Interviews kommen oder die zu schalten
kommen diese Gäste und bringen sie dann
teilweise auch hier in die Maske da
siehst du ja schon wie es jemandem geht
du siehst auch wie sich die Leute über
Zeit verändern und ich habe hier schon
Kabinett Mitglieder begrüßt wo ich
angefangen habe mir Sorgen zu machen und
mir gedacht habe Mensch die könnten mal
eine ruhige Minute gebrauchen in der sie
sich wirklich ausruhen und vielleicht
auch mal ausschlafen können und Robert
Habeck hat das ja sogar mal in der
Öffentlichkeit gesagt das ist jetzt kein
Scheiß den ich erzähle die Leute werden
krank die haben Burnout die kriegen
Tinnitus die können nicht mehr weil es
immer die gleichen Leute sind die die
gleichen Gesetze machen weil das Haus so
aufgebaut ist wow das hört sich in der
Tat krass an was hat das denn jetzt
bedeutet für all die Projekte die man
sich ursprünglich meinem
Koalitionsvertrag vorgenommen hatte das
ist ja relativ schwer zu messen und die
Legislaturperiode ist noch nicht vorbei
aber es gibt eine ganz gute Seite den
prima Überblick schafft das ist fragt
den staat.de die haben einen
koalitionstracker gemacht und die sagen
sie haben 250 messbare Projekte der
Koalition identifiziert und die gucken
dann wie viele sind umgesetzt wie viele
sind verschoben und wenn man momentan
haben sie angefangen und da gibt es
momentan nur ein gutes dutzendprojekte
die tatsächlich schon umgesetzt sind das
ist natürlich erstmal nicht viel aber
man darf eben nicht vergessen die
gesamte Krisenpolitik die dann nebenher
läuft bzw die hauptsächlich läuft und
das heißt man muss es auch unter diesem
Gesichtspunkt bewerten was da alles
geleistet wird okay und da muss man
natürlich sehen ist es ein Viertel
dieser Legislatur um auch hier braucht
man natürlich eine Note zum Ende für die
Kopfnote Fleiß was gibt es von Dir dann
bin ich vielleicht wegen des ganzen
Drucks ein bisschen milde gestimmt weil
es eben Krisenpolitik ist und das was
die Koalition selber noch gestalten will
dann würde ich sagen mal so eine
motivierende 2 plus 2 plus heißt also
1,7 danke dir stark unterler und wir
notieren die 1,7
womit wir nun alle einzeln Noten
zusammen haben welche Gesamtnote bekommt
die Ampel also jetzt wie ihr erstes
regierungswerk natürlich ist das auch
immer kennt ihr sichern aus der Schule
wenn z.B deutscharbeiten zurück habe
nicht so ganz leicht eine total gerechte
Bewertung vorzunehmen wir haben uns Mühe
gegeben möglichst viele wichtige
Faktoren einfließen zu lassen und fair
zu bewerten was also kommt raus an alle
einzeln Noten notiert und im Schnitt
ergibt das eine
3,5 und jetzt noch wie angekündigt die
Frage an euch ja was sagt ihr welche
Note hättet ihr für angemessen und warum
bitte macht mit wenn ihr Lust habt bei
unserem Bewertungstool gibt da eure Note
ab und schreibt die Begründung dafür
gerne in die Kommentare dann können wir
vergleichen bei wem die Ampel insgesamt
besser abschneidet bei uns beim inside
politics Redaktionsteam oder beim inside
politics Publikum will sie jetzt
überlege ich gerade noch ob ich
irgendwas
du bist noch irgendwie abbinden
ja bin wir das jetzt irgendwie ab ich
würde sagen am besten so wie wir
angefangen haben mit ein paar
Einschätzungen von
Bundestagsabgeordneten zu einem Jahr
Ampel 40 bemüht dass er mir Energie hier
kriegen bemüht unter extrem schwierigen
Bedingungen es manches erreicht worden
aber noch nicht alles was notwendig ist
immer dann wenn sie die Vorschläge die
wir gemacht haben auch umgesetzt haben
dann haben sie es richtig gemacht nur
leider auch immer ein halbes Jahr zu
spät
was müsste sich verbessern wenn ich das
sage lachen alle in die Energie die in
die Schmerzhaftigkeit führt mehr nach
innen zu führen als nach außen der wird
mir jetzt zumindest einer einfallen der
da wohl zustimmen würde ja und zum
Abschluss haben wir uns dann noch einige
verraten was früher so auf ihren
Zeugnissen stand vorausgesetzt sie hat
uns schon ich kann mich nicht mehr ganz
genau erinnern im Gegensatz zu ihnen bin
ich ja etwas älter man glaubt es heute
kaum aber in der Grundschule das habe
ich neulich noch gesehen stand in meinem
zeugnisheft Renate beteiligt sich zu
wenig ist mir unerklärlich in einem
Zeugnis stand Christian ehrlich seine
Aufgaben sehr sorgfältig aber nicht
immer in der dafür vorgesehenen Zeit ja
zum Glück bleiben der Ampere ja noch
drei Jahre wir sind auch ein bisschen
länger geworden mit unserer
Zeugnisausgabe als wir dachten war aber
eben auch ein besonderes Jahr großes
Dankeschön an euch für euer Interesse
auch in diesem ersten Ampel ja lasst uns
gerne ein Abo da wenn das nicht schon
getan habt schaut euch wenn ihr mögt
noch mal das ein oder andere einzelvideo
von Politik an die links stehen auch
alle noch mal unten in der Beschreibung
ja und dann bleibt uns nur noch zu sagen
tschüss bis zum nächsten mal was war als
echt gut